Connecting DesignaKnit to your Brother
electronic machine is a matter
of connecting the BL1 or the BL5 cable
between the machine and your
computer with DAK installed.
The USB cable has three parts.
The USB end connects to a USB
port on your computer.
The square end with the small
prongs connects to the machine.
On the 930, 940, remove the small plastic
cover to reveal the port
on the back of the machine.
On the 970, the port is on the CB1 box.
With the two ends now connected,
the computer can now talk to the machine.
Next, position the black box,
and I'm sure there's a better name for it,
on the body of the machine
near the row counter.
Position it with the red dot facing
the front of the machine
and the cable tables towards the back.
Use Velcro to attach this so you can
easily remove it to use
it with other machines.
Finally, position the Knitlink
magnet arm to the K-carriage.
Position it so it passes
in front of the black box.
On the 970, be sure that the arm
clears the manual row counter.
As you pass the magnet,
a red light will blink and a will be sent
to DesignaKnit to record that you've
passed the carriage and you've knit a row.
You need to let DesignaKnit know what
machine you're using and connect
the computer to DesignaKnit.
I'm in Standard Garment Styling
and from the menu, I'll choose >Options,
click >Method of Knitting,
then choose >Machine, and click >OK.
Click the >Setup button and then
click >Find Link and >start search.
DesignaKnit will connect to your
computer to set things up.
A message will display when
the connection is made.
Click >OK.
Scroll to choose your
machine and then click >OK.
With everything in place,
your machine and DesignaKnit will
be able to talk to each other.
In interactive Knitting,
the magnet will let DesignaKnit know you've
knit a row, and DesignaKnit will give
you your knitting instructions.
In Stitch Designer, this setup will allow
you to download stitch patterns to your
machine or upload built-in stitch patterns
to DesignaKnit so that you can modify them.
If you'd like to learn more about using
DesignaKnit , please visit learnDesignaKnit.
Com.